In America,
we tend to think that the news is all
about us all the time.
At some level,
you really can't blame us though.
Just turn on CNN or Fox News or Msnbc
and all you get these days is endless
election coverage with like a tiny bit
of national news and maybe a minute,
an hour on the international front.
Occasionally when something big flairs
up the talking heads,
we'll focus on Syria or North Korea or
Iran for a couple days,
but then it's quickly back to the usual
grind.
Even when something huge like brexit is
happening.
We barely talk about it in the u s until
the very last second when suddenly every
pundit who hasn't mentioned it once in
the past year is supposedly an expert
beyond hearing about terror attacks,
we barely even talk about the countries
we have the most in common with.
Once the initial response to the attack
is over,
has anything happened in the UK since
brexit?
What's been happening in France since
the Paris attacks?
How are the toppest in Spain or the
pasta in Italy or the cheese in Denmark?
You might know and I might know,
but I bet it's from alternative news
sources and social media and not from
mainstream television.
The danger of only hearing about other
countries when bad things happen like
terror attacks,
riots and scandals,
is that you begin to think that's all
that there is to these other places as
well as the citizens that live there
themselves.
Imagine if other countries only
associated Americans with our current
election,
many already do,
and that is pretty Shitty,
although possibly warranted every
country on earth.
Every single one has elements in it that
are good and that are bad.
This doesn't mean that every country or
every culture is equal.
Obviously this is not the case,
but every country is made up of all
sorts of people with all sorts of
beliefs.
As I've said often on the show,
the ultimate minorities,
the individual judging an entire group
as a collective,
we'll almost always assure you,
dismiss huge amounts of people who don't
fit the stereotype or the narrative.
I've said this before and I'll say it
again and one of the things that I'm
most proud of about the Ruben report is
that our audience is truly worldwide.
When we did our fan shore a couple of
months ago,
we got messages from people in over 60
countries.
We chose people based on their
individual attributes,
not because we expected them to
represent an entire nation.
While our mainstream media does a pretty
poor job of showing that we have more in
common than what separates us,
I find that people like you,
the ones watching this right now do an
incredibly good job of it.
The conversations I see you having in
the comments sections right here on
twitter and on facebook or even on your
own youtube videos are connecting people
from all over the world.
I see you guys constantly trying to cut
through the nonsense and have real
conversations and find some common
ground together is the only way that
we'll have a chance to truly be hurt.
My guest this week is Australian
journalist Rida Panahi.
Rita grew up in Iran in a Muslim family
and emigrated to Australia.
She was six years old.
She's now a fierce defender of western
values and spends much of her time
writing about the same issues I talk
about on this show.
We're going to talk about her childhood
in Iran as well as her life in
Australia.
Is there more to that giant island
country than just boomerangs and
Kangaroos?
I suspect there might just be,
to prove my earlier point,
when was the last time you heard
anything in the news about Australia
since the terrorist attack in Sydney
almost two years ago.
They had a nationwide election about two
months ago,
but I think I only heard about that
because of a random link on twitter.
If you're watching this,
you are,
you've already shared much of the
mainstream nonsense,
but our work is still cut out for us.
Let's keep talking to interesting people
from all over the world and if you've
got suggestions,
well,
there's a comment section right down
below.
Yeah.
Rita Pinar,
he is a journalist who was born in
America,
spent her first year is in Iran and has
lived in Australia ever since.
Rita,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me.
Greetings from Melbourne.
Greetings from Los Angeles.
I'm going to,
I want to dive into some Australia stuff
cause we never hear anything about
Australia in America.
I mean nothing since Crocodile Dundee
too.
We haven't heard anything from you guys.
Uh,
but let's start a little bit with your
history.
Cause you have a really interesting
You were actually born in the United
States,
but you never lived in the United
States.
Correct.
Okay.
No,
not really.
I spent my first couple of years there.
My parents were there,
my dad was studying,
he was,
um,
getting his degree in Arkansas.
So I was born in,
down in pine bluff,
Arkansas.
And then we moved back to the ranch was
always the plan and then the Islamic
revolution happened.
So things went,
pay shaped,
you ran quite quickly.
And we're sort of a trap now in a
country that was entirely different to
before the revolution.
Um,
and ended up in Australia.
And I'm,
I'm really grateful to be here really.
So it's a wonderful place.
I know you guys think America is the
center of the world,
but I really think Australia is that the
lucky country as we call it and in any
body can do well in this country.
Yeah.
And I've heard you say that in speeches
before that you really think Australia
is the true place of tolerance and where
everyone can come and make a better life
and all that sort of stuff.
So your parents,
so they moved to,
to the states that your,
your dad was teaching or something.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
well when he was in the states,
he was getting his degree,
so he was at university and as soon as
he graduated,
they moved back.
That was always the plan.
Um,
and uh,
and then when you ran,
went to hell,
half of the Islamic Revolution,
um,
they started looking at how they could
get at,
cause uh,
they,
um,
will fairly persecuted there and they,
they,
um,
well it just wasn't safe.
When we had family members walked up and
sending them in,
killed it,
it was really hell on earth for our
family.
So we,
um,
we're looking to leave and the plan was
always to come back to the states.
Um,
but my dad had a brother in Australia
and um,
we ended up here.
It wasn't the plan,
but,
um,
it was,
it was a lucky,
lucky chance.
Yeah.
People don't realize that before the
Islamic revolution.
I mean a rod was a,
was a widely secular state and a lot of
ways,
much more secular than it is now.
I know you were really young when you
were there,
but what are your memories from being
five or six years old?
Look out of the feeling limited
memories,
but I mean,
yeah,
it was one of the more western parts of
the Middle East.
You know,
you look at pictures of Tara and back in
before the revolution and you know,
you see women in miniskirts and I,
men and women mixing freely and women at
beaches.
You know,
we used to live by the beach before
we're in Turan.
Um,
and then things changed dramatically in,
you know,
it really brings home just how quickly
things can degenerate into what we see
now.
I mean,
the rants progressed a little bit from
when the revolution first happened as
far as its treatment of women,
but it's still pretty bloody poor.
Um,
you know,
I remember having to go to school and
then suddenly going from being fairly
carefree and not having to cover my hair
to being in an age women at five,
six years old,
where,
you know,
that was a time where you had to wear
the hijab.
That was a requirement and it was just
completely dehumanizing and I just loved
it.
I liked that change even just in my
little life from when I was running
around with the boys and being a regular
kid to being expected to observe these
moral codes,
like making sure my hair's covered and
behaving in a certain way.
Um,
so even that as a,
at a tender age,
it,
I felt the full force of it.
Um,
always knew I was an American citizens.
So for me,
I always identified as someone other
than,
um,
someone had to live the rest of their
life under that oppressive system.
So it was,
um,
it was significant for me and I was
like,
we have one of the original anchor
babies.
I was like,
I,
I can't get out one day when I made
team,
I'm not going to have to be here.
So that really was a source of comfort
to me,
even as a very young child,
that one day I'd get out of this.
What a fascinating time to grow up
because it's not like people having
their formative years when there isn't
change where you just were going through
what you had to go through,
but to go from,
even though you were very young to
having memories of freedom and that,
and then as,
as a five year old or whatever that you,
you knew something was wrong with being
forced into that kind of system.
That's it.
And you know,
and even now that keeps them sticking to
the young girls,
you know,
for the first years,
they don't have to cover up and they can
run around and then they don't have
these obligations on them.
But when they start school,
then the hijabs have to be worn.
And you know,
that,
uh,
know not the best things when you've got
a stinking hot day,
nevermind that the rest of the year.
Um,
and yeah,
breaks my heart when I see that.
When you see the kids,
that girl's been tickled out having to,
you know,
transition from just being a kid and to
bang,
you know,
part of the regime.
Yeah.
What was it like to actually get out?
I mean,
you said your dad had a brother in
Australia.
I assume the regime probably didn't want
their,
their bright young people to leave.
No.
I know we,
um,
we were really lucky to be accepted in
Australia.
My mom,
uh,
was a midwife.
She was actually,
she was the head midwife at a hospital
there that was,
um,
attended by the royal family before the
Islamic Revolution.
So it was a lot of pictures of her
showing the role family around the
facilities.
You know,
that was a fairly regular thing with
that come and visit and she'd be the one
responsible,
she was a bit of a glamor,
glamor,
Paulson,
you know,
look the,
um,
so they really feared for their life
because there were publications and
pictures of her with the royal family.
And you think that might be a minor
thing.
People got killed for that,
you know,
people we know,
um,
got,
got in prison.
So,
um,
we were lucky to,
uh,
like I said,
the intention wasn't to stay in
Australia,
but we ended up staying here and a were
granted asylum and it was,
um,
uh,
just,
you know,
forever indebted,
indebted to the country because of that,
because he gave us a chance at a new
life.
Yeah.
What kind of culture shock was that?
Like a six year old going from Iran in
the,
in the Middle East to,
to an island,
uh,
with,
you know,
people in,
in Boardshorts,
um,
uh,
will be boarding and all that.
Oh,
absolutely.
And,
and the language was a shock too
because,
um,
even though I was born in the states,
I had zero English because I'd been
brought up in your end.
So I had like two words,
hello.
And T,
which is a weird combination of woods
deny.
So I had to learn the language very
quickly.
Um,
but it's such a welcoming place and
thankfully English is a very simple
language for a child to learn.
So it only took a few months and um,
and yeah,
it is a bit of a culture shock,
but Australia is not that different that
the,
you guys imagine any guys think they,
we never got Kangaroos,
you know,
just a hobby.
Yeah.
I assume you have a boomerang within
reaching distance of you right now.
Oh,
wise,
I'd never leave home without a
boomerang.
You never know when you need it.
Yeah.
It's um,
yeah,
it was a culture shock.
Definitely.
You know,
you made,
it really felt safe and very quickly you
realize,
you know,
this is a really welcoming,
um,
you know,
wonderful to,
to grow up and so much opportunity.
Yeah.
Uh,
did you experience any discrimination or
anything like that or really was it just
simply you were there
30 years and I've been here now for like
over 13 years so you know,
I have seen um,
occasional discrimination but really it
is minor and um,
it's been,
um,
quite often then the discrimination I
say are from your,
you know,
your bloody social justice warriors as
opposed to be the most tolerant,
you know,
open minded people in the world.
But if you don't conform to their idea
of what a brown person should be saying
and doing and thinking then that quite
often really vicious and beneath that
seem to be near of goodness is,
is a bigot.
Um,
and I've seen that quite a lot on
twitter.
That's probably the most racism I've
ever faced has been on twitter from,
from the lunatic left.
Right.
Because your,
because somehow you're a brown.
Do you do identify as Muslim?
Do you consider yourself ex Muslim or do
you consider yourself Muslim?
Cool myself,
eggs,
x moles on my family and was one like if
you ask them what's your religion next
time was lump and then very,
very relaxed about it.
They were Muslim in the way most
Australians are Christian.
Um,
as one big difference between Australia
and America where a lot less religious
than than you guys.
And um,
and so,
but as early as I could remember
identified as atheist,
I just didn't believe.
And um,
so for me there wasn't a real big
transition from being a Muslim to being
an agnostic or an atheist because I
never was practicing,
you know,
I don't think my parents had ever been
to a mosque.
Um,
right.
Certainly not me.
So they're not at all devout.
So That's interesting that the,
the discrimination which you faced,
what you're describing is very little
and mostly on twitter,
which is not reality.
I keep trying to remind myself that
twitter's not reality,
but you're getting,
you're getting the discrimination from
the social justice crew because your not
your,
not their type of brown person because
you do speak your mind.
Absolutely.
It is extraordinary that these people
who supposedly spend their lives
fighting for the,
for the minorities,
that,
you know,
they see as a pitcher,
you're pressed,
even in countries like Australia and
when are,
he actually speaks up and has their own
thoughts.
They,
and it doesn't conform to their world
view.
They are absolutely appalling in,
in their response,
uh,
straight out bigotry.
Um,
and you know,
it's like if you were sitting rice or if
you're from a minority group,
you should only vote a certain way.
You know,
you're not allowed the opportunity to
think for yourself and decide for
yourself who,
who you're going to support or where
you're going to stand on certain issues.
Um,
and yeah,
like I said,
but beneath that thin veneer of virtue,
quite often there's a really hateful
bigot when,
when someone is,
um,
you know,
identifies as a social justice warrior
and I've got no qualms or bad mocking
them day and night.
I just think there are quite often hard
people who deserve to be called out.
Yeah.
And you get a lot of crap for calling
them out,
but it doesn't stop you.
But I agree.
Of course.
I mean it's such a dim view of the world
that they have that we should all be
viewed in.
This collective is space.
But before we go all in on that stuff,
tell me a little bit about Australia
because boomerangs and Kangaroos and
reverse coriolis effect in your toilet
aside.
I feel like nobody in the states knows
anything about Australia.
You're a big island.
That's pretty much it.
Well,
our big island,
most of the population lives along the
coast love desert in the middle.
Um,
it's a really modern,
uh,
I think it's a lot like the states,
except we're not really just,
uh,
that's one of the things we look at you
and we don't sort of identify when we've
had a prime minister who was an atheist
and we had no issue with that at all.
I mean,
she was a terrible prime minister,
but not because she was an atheist.
No,
no.
That had nothing to do with it.
Um,
we've had a lot of prime minister's
recently.
We've had a,
a modern history of being really stable,
particularly politically,
but in the last six,
seven years,
we seem to just keep knifing our prime
minister's was they getting elected and
then their own party nights them.
And then we have another one.
So that's kind of characterize the
politics in recent years.
And we've got a conservative government
at the moment,
but led by a man who many conservatives
don't really see as a conservative.
So it's a really interesting period.
And he just hung on,
um,
because a lot of the conservative base
abandoned their party and went and voted
for minor parties.
So it's really interesting seeing what's
happening around the world with you guys
because there does seem to be this,
uh,
uprising from,
from conservatives where they don't
actually think that the major parties or
the,
the major,
uh,
establishment,
I guess isn't really representing their
interests.
And in Australia we had,
you know,
a lot of minor parties and some of them
describe as far right,
um,
a lot of boats in the last election this
year.
Yeah.
So I think Americans think that
everybody is like us.
Like,
oh,
we're a two party system.
Even though I keep saying on the show,
the constitution never says anything
about only having two parties.
It's just that the two parties have a
strangle their system.
You guys have a bunch of parties that
sort of trade power and,
uh,
and it's not just two parties on top of
everything,
right?
That's right.
Well,
we've got a labor,
which is your predominant left party.
We've got at the conservatives,
which are liberal and national and they
are in a coalition together.
And then we've got a minor party called
the grains,
which they like wanting 10 votes.
So,
um,
in the Senate,
our Apple House,
they have to have a presence.
But this last election,
the minor from all we had facets,
you know,
the,
our senate isn't the absolute dog's
breakfast,
you know,
is,
it's going to be fascinating to see how
we can govern for the next few years
because you've got so many months,
so many minor parties that I have got
their own little objection objectives
and you wonder how they're going to work
together,
um,
and,
and a gray and passed legislation.
So,
um,
so yeah,
we do,
we have a very different system to you.
It's a party based system.
We don't like for a,
for a Labor prime minister we've like
for our representative in our local
seat,
so it's a little bit uh,
different.
Um,
but though we don't directly both for
the prime minister,
whoever is leading them parties
significant obviously and know it has a
fair,
fair deal to do with who gets elected.
Yeah.
So it's kind of,
there's benefits and drawbacks to both,
right?
Because here,
oh,
definitely.
Yeah,
there is.
There is.
Um,
and you know,
you've got,
particularly in the Senate when you've
got so many different parties now he can
have the vote diluted and our senate is
a really weird system.
Every single stage is entitled to the
same number of senators.
So you might have a very populous state
like New South Wales or Victoria,
but we get the same number of senators
as Tasmania,
which is,
you know,
I know what it is there.
So it's not a one vote,
one value.
So it's,
it's,
it's mad.
I mean,
I,
I'd be very much for abolishing our
Senate after the house because it's very
much obstructionist and
unrepresentative.
But,
um,
that ain't going to happen anytime soon.
It's an argument that's been made
decades and,
and you know,
it's still there,
right?
Uh,
I'm curious it being an island,
I mean,
being just a day,
the fact that you guys are so big
geographically and that you're an eye on
how much of that actually plays into
sorta the national eat those because you
know,
like when we see what's going on with
the European Union and borders and all
that stuff,
these are people that are landlocked
next to each other.
You know,
borders and immigration are important,
all that kind of stuff.
And you guys really have the advantage
of water.
I mean,
it really is just that simple in a way.
But how much is that actually like
affect policies and the way people think
about the rest of the world and all that
kinds of stuff?
Oh look,
we've got oceans and yeah,
geographically we are blessed to be
apart from a lot of that turmoil.
But those oceans didn't stop 50,000
people coming here by boat.
And when Labor was in government,
and we had a very strict border control
system under the conservative government
of,
of John Howard,
and when labour were elected,
they completely dismantled that because
that's not,
that wasn't in their thinking.
They thought it was more humane to,
to be a little bit more tolerant.
But that tolerance led to hundreds of
people over 1200 people drowning when
our borders trying to come here from
places like Indonesia by boat,
they went Indonesians that travel from
typically the Middle East.
Right.
So there are migrant,
yeah,
it's actually from other countries that
use it.
That's right.
Yeah.
Typically economic migrants,
I'm,
I'm sure there was some genuine refugees
amongst them,
but the overwhelming majority you would
describe as economic migrants and even
the Labor Party came to acknowledge that
and they started toughening up.
And right now they're,
well,
they say they back all the border
protection policies that the
conservative side have and,
and you know,
then they're not going to dismantle
everything because it led to enormous
suffering,
not just the 1200 people be drowned
trying to get here,
women and children amongst them,
but also all our detention centers
field.
You know,
we have 50,000,
we had 50,000,
I think even more than that in detention
centers,
you know,
effectively locked up.
And since we've managed to take regain
control of our borders,
those detention centers have emptied
out.
There's not people drowning on the
border.
Um,
and we still have a refugee program.
We still have a humanitarian intake,
in fact increased it.
But we select people who are waiting and
observing the rules because you know
what people,
there was a period where people would
argue that there are no cues to come
here.
And you know,
they're,
these programs don't exist.
But as we know they do exist and there's
people floundering,
waiting in camps,
um,
who don't have the resources to hop on a
plane to Indonesia and then pay a people
smuggler to come by boat to Australia
and then now priority.
So we,
uh,
ab refugee and take I think is something
to really be really proud of because we
are very generous with that.
Um,
and you know,
this isn't just simply porous borders.
This is a proper humanitarian program
where these people are brought here,
they even housing healthcare education
and you know,
help to,
to become integrated into society.
What Rita Rita,
I thought you were supposed to be a cold
hearted,
heartless,
conservative who,
who wants to close borders and all that.
But it sounds like you're actually okay
with immigration as you are an immigrant
yourself,
but you just want,
you just want reasonable standards to
absolutely.
I'm willing to go.
What would would this country
particularly economically needs are
economic migrants.
They bring a great deal of wealth and
you know,
we're an aging nation.
We need people to who are working age
and come here and are productive and
contribute well,
our humanitarian intake,
we've got to be honest,
it costs us a lot of money,
but it is something I think that,
um,
as a rich nation we're obliged to do and
I'm proud of that.
However,
that doesn't mean that it's a free for
all and whoever,
you know,
I can just a break the rules,
come here and come here first.
Also,
we've got to be mindful of where those
refugees are coming from because of
late,
there has been issues with,
uh,
some not integrating as they should and
as immigrants decades before them have
integrated.
Um,
so there is lot of debate in this
country about where should these
refugees come from,
you know,
where do we,
do we prioritize?
Christians are being persecuted in,
in the Middle East,
he's eighties.
Um,
or do we not consider religion at all?
And just bring in whoever's,
um,
you know,
Dean,
the neediest.
Um,
there was a poll just this week that was
published.
Those absolutely blown people away.
It was a,
it was a poll that was uh,
you know,
by one of the more left leaning
pollsters.
So you know,
there can be no sort of accusations and
you know,
it was published in the Guardian says it
came in accusations of this was some
sort of a rogue pole too to try to
change public sentiment.
But he showed one in two Australians
supports an immediate ban on Muslim
migration.
Now this is absolutely shocked.
So many people who just refuse to accept
that this sort of sentiment is out there
and it's there because people don't talk
about this issue.
People pretend that,
you know,
terrorism isn't happening,
that it doesn't have a religion.
And,
and you know,
most Australians are smarter than that
now.
I don't actually agree with the
immediate ban on Muslim,
on migration.
I'm not for that at all.
But I can understand and,
and the pole didn't surprise me because
you know,
I don't think exist in this little tiny
echo chamber that so many of the media
seem to existing where I just think we
need to talk about these things openly.
Cause when you don't,
that's when you have sent them in life.
This rising,
and I don't think it's particularly
healthy.
So isn't that the ultimate irony of,
of your position for you particularly
because as an immigrant from the Middle
East,
it's,
it's extremely personal to you.
But for me and the people that are in
our space that we see on twitter that
are talking about this stuff that aren't
doing it from a bigoted place that want
to help people when we can and all that,
but also what a proper bedding they've
put us in a,
in a really bizarre situation.
And for you,
I mean I've seen you go on tv and I saw
something where you are on tv debating
this guy and I anchor and he kept
implying you were saying all Muslims
repeatedly.
Even even though you never said it.
Well we'll link to it below so people
can see it.
You never said it.
It was the,
it was the age old argument that we have
all the time here.
And it's like,
man,
she's from the Middle East.
She was born to Muslim parents.
She immigrated properly.
Now she's trying to stand up for the
very values that this country is four
and they're doing this to you too.
This bizarro alliance between the
regressive left and Islamist is
prevalent every way.
You know,
in the UK,
the US and even in Australia and it is
bloody seat.
It doesn't make any sense.
The only sense it makes is that they
share a common enemy conservatives.
But I think you're talking about,
um,
appearance on morning television.
I had written a piece about,
you know,
this terror has an,
has a religion and we've got to
acknowledge it.
Again,
I was at pains as we always are.
Um,
to say I'm talking about is limits until
a little bad.
The extremist,
I'm not talking about that in time was
the long,
you know,
all those qualifications were made,
but no,
nevertheless,
you know,
even just talking about it,
Ebony and identifying what is happening
that is clear to anybody who hasn't got
their head buried in the sand was a pour
into this dude.
And he brought up Christian terrorism,
you know,
bombings at abortion clinics,
which I think,
you know,
the last one was that he could find was
about 15,
20 years ago.
But nevertheless,
you know,
you can't talk about Muslim based or
Islam as space terror without mentioning
the Christian.
You know,
it's just,
it was pretty great because you asked
him when the last one was and he had no
idea that he busted out his phone in a
few minutes later,
came back and yeah,
it turned out to be 15 or 20 years ago.
I'm curious,
you know,
because you guys haven't been hit with
terrorism really until about two years
ago in Sydney and there was that hostage
situation and all that was,
how much did that actually change the
discussion for you guys because you were
seeing it everywhere else again,
surrounded by water,
seemingly safe.
Um,
did that really change the discussion in
the country?
Okay.
Did the Lindt cafe siege in Sydney and
there's been other events?
It just a short time before that,
there was a,
a young kitten,
Melvin,
who was radicalized and,
uh,
he tried to kill a couple of police
officers,
stabbed and repeatedly he was shot dead.
That was probably our first taste of it.
Um,
linked effected the public.
It wasn't just targeted at police,
but we've been really fortunate in this
country.
We've had our counter terrorism offices,
uh,
and authorities foil several plots.
We've just had some,
uh,
someone in prison for what was a called
the Anzac Day,
Tara Palantir.
Really significant date within our,
within our calendar,
the plot plot there was to run over a
police officer,
behead them,
take their gun and shoot more people.
Um,
we've had a mother's Day plot that's
with before the courts now,
which was again,
uh,
you know,
going to be tired in the public from the
information that's out there.
So there's,
there's been,
um,
and,
and the biggest one we had was all about
a decade ago,
if not longer.
Um,
you know,
about a decade ago,
which was a quite advanced plans to bomb
the Melbourne cricket ground,
which is our biggest sporting stadium
here.
So we've been really fortunate that
these plots have been,
um,
stopped in their tracks.
But those lone wolf attacks as we call
them,
they're not so easily stopped.
And,
and it has been a,
we had a police member shot in Sydney
last year,
um,
in an attack by a young kid,
I think it was 15,
16,
who was again,
radicalized.
So we've had a taste of it,
but no way.
Like,
yeah,
places like France and Belgium where
there issues seem to be so advanced that
you want to have they ever going to get
on top of it.
Yeah.
Is that the irony too is that it's like
the better that our security services
are,
the more things that they stop.
And often we don't know that they
stopped them until sometimes months or
years later.
And then at the same time it makes the
threat seem lower.
So then people want to be more tolerant.
And again,
tolerance basically is good.
Uh,
but you don't have a full picture.
And I guess that's really what the,
the big issue is
absolutely.
You can become complacent.
I know we don't live in fear here.
We don't think you know,
over what was going to be blowing off
around the street corner.
But again,
you've just got to be awake to the
reality of what's happening around the
world and that we are not immune from
it.
You know,
the terror denies around here we'll
bring up things like what you got much
more chance of,
you know,
dying in a car crash.
Right.
Cool.
Bloody do you know,
we drive around,
they got millions of cars but you know,
do we not think about terror and we
don't worry about that and make sure we
kept doing things to counter it.
Um,
yeah.
Do we not worry about domestic violence
because more people are dying on the
roads from car accidents.
I mean,
it is just a stupid argument.
There is just so much that is
intellectually dishonest and,
and just fraudulent in my mind when it
comes to this space because people will
do anything not to talk about it.
People will do anything to deny that
it's even an issue.
And it obviously is an issue on this
poll that came out this week show is
that it is an issue and people are
thinking about it.
Even if our elite median politicians
aren't willing to discuss it.
Yeah.
Can you think of anything else that were
so paralyzed to talk about?
Cause I really can't in 2016 is there
anything else that we treat with such
kid gloves that is of such importance
and I,
and I get email from people literally
all over the world from almost every
country saying that their governments
are doing the exact same thing.
Yeah.
It seems to,
yeah.
Not Be.
Every western nation seems to be dealing
with it in Australia.
I think the other issue that is,
seems to be to do,
uh,
but is a significant issue is what's
happening in a lot of indigenous
communities.
Again,
it's something that people don't talk
about because if you do talk about it
and he can get labeled a racist very
quickly,
even though you care enough to want to
actually do something about an attack,
lease,
put it on the public to public or
discuss it.
Even we've got kids who are being really
mistreated,
neglected,
okay.
And they're not being saved by the
authorities.
They're not being taken into care at the
same level as you would expect.
Uh,
I mean,
sorry,
let me rephrase that.
They actually are taking in to care at
greater rates then,
then the non indigenous community,
but at the point where the authorities
typed them seems to be a,
you know,
a lot higher than then.
You know,
no white kid I don't think would be
allowed to be mistreated in that way for
so long before they are saved.
And we,
we've got this nurse stolen generation
narrative in our history that,
that the authorities are scared now to
actually save kids who are being abused.
And,
and because of that political
correctness,
because they don't want to create
another stolen generation of the
indigenous kids taken from their
parents.
But those kids are condemned to just
terrible lives.
You know,
their,
they're,
they repeat the cycle.
They,
and,
and I think that's just such a great
shame and there is that there is a
really significant gap in,
in living standards in life expectancy
in outcomes.
Right.
Did you in this community compared to
the non indigenous community.
And I believe a great deal of that has
to do with these politically correct
policies where we can't talk about
what's happening.
We can't talk about the rampant abuse,
sexual abuse.
We can't talk about the alcoholism,
the drug use because to,
to even start discussing it is,
is,
is racist.
You know,
the arguments will come up with what
about all the drug use and alcoholism
and the non indigenous community?
Well,
yes,
of course.
But that doesn't stop.
Yeah.
It's exactly the same sort of phenomenon
happening there and it's just as
destructive and it actually hurts the
people that they're trying to protect
from,
from discussion.
Right.
And we see that,
we see that exact same thing when it
comes to the discussion on Islam because
if we don't talk about it,
then who are you hurting the most?
You're actually hurting Muslim people
who are living under these theocracies
killed the most and oppress the most are
other Muslims and Islamic state and
looks at Shiite Muslims like my family
as infidels.
No different from,
from Jews or a nonbelievers gays,
you know,
they,
they think they're deserving of nothing
other than death as well.
So,
um,
and extremist Islam as have been killing
other Muslims,
you know,
at a rate that is extraordinary for
decades and we just don't,
it's almost not on our radar anymore
because it happens so often
about the abortion bombing in the
Crusades.
Well,
that's it.
even google.
Yeah.
What about the Crusades?
I mean,
God's sake,
some of the arguments that are thrown up
are just,
they're just too stupid.
But you've got to acknowledge them when
you've got to counter them because
they're being taught in universities.
You know,
I've had these sort of arguments with
university lecturers and journalists and
you know,
pay academics who are on public purse
and I just spewing forth bullshit and
it's maddening.
Spewing forth bullshit.
That could be the title of a,
of a book that we should probably call
write that book.
So jumping back for a second,
talking about Australia's role in the
world,
what is the Australian sort of ethos
about what you feel your role should be?
Obviously you guys aren't that
interventionists,
but you've been part of coalitions and
things like that.
What is the,
the feeling there of what your purpose
in the world should be?
Well,
pretty laid back about things.
We don't try to sort of sit the agenda
agender or,
um,
you know,
in four our belief systems.
But we have been a good corporates.
The corporates,
we've been global citizen.
Oh Man.
Slip is going to be replayed many,
many times.
Um,
but yeah,
we will,
I think,
you know,
I,
I'm used to,
we can be quite proud of,
um,
uh,
involvement in World War Two,
our involvement,
um,
uh,
you know,
with the allied forces.
And I think,
you know,
we do feel a little bit removed
geographically.
We are so far from so much of what's
happening around the world,
but these days,
you know,
it's all there in your hand and your
phone and it's,
it's,
it's immediate.
You know,
what's happening as soon as it happens,
you know,
it's,
uh,
we are living in a time where,
you know,
those,
those borders don't seem to mean as
much.
So I think,
um,
we're feeling relaxed about our place in
the world.
Uh,
you know,
when we do have those amongst us,
as you have been Erie community who
wants to set the agenda,
they want to be,
you know,
yeah,
we had a carbon tax for a while and,
you know,
the rationale was there.
We,
you know,
we got to lead the world in an emission
trading scheme.
We're going to be the standard bearers
in a fighting global warming.
And,
uh,
the government got thrown out really
quickly,
so yeah,
that didn't last too long.
So I think overall it's Australians
recognize a pretty lucky,
we got a very good standard of living.
We've got our own concerns.
Um,
all sorts of issues from housing
affordability to uh,
the threat of terror.
Um,
but um,
I think we're,
yeah,
we're pretty happy with
saying what's happening around the world
and,
and feeling fortunate that it's not
happening in our back yard yet.
Yeah,
it's,
I'm telling you it's that water thing
being big and surrounded by water.
It's,
it's pretty good.
Um,
what do,
what do you make of our crazy election
here at Natalie?
What do you make of it?
But what kind of coverage in Australia
just in mainstream media is our election
getting?
Cause it's all,
it's all we have here.
Any of the Cable News,
24 hour days,
that's all we talk about.
Okay.
Are we getting a lot,
a lot more than previously?
There is a lot of American election
coverage in our mainstream news,
that particular television,
great deal of it and all of it.
Almost all of it is pretty much what
you'd expect.
It's very much,
you know,
trump is this maniac who's a racist and
sexist.
And you know,
some of the reports I've seen,
she's wasted.
They just straight.
And news reports have been,
again,
an extraordinary in,
in being little,
you know,
editorials that are absolutely biased.
Um,
personally,
um,
I don't know what,
I mean,
I've got a great deal of thoughts.
I'm not a fan of either candidate.
Um,
I can't believe it's easy astic for
trump,
but I completely understand the
phenomenon.
I understand people being utterly fed up
and wanting an antiestablishment figure.
Um,
and I know why he appeals to people.
I think a lot of things that the media
sees gaps and sees huge errors in his
character.
I actually enormous assets and a of what
appealed to a lot of people.
So,
um,
it's been just fascinating.
I would love to be there for the last
month or two and just say had on phones.
Um,
but you know,
trump,
some of his greatest enemies are,
again,
he's great.
Assess it.
So you look at what's happening now with
the protests in,
in Charlotte and um,
you know,
the,
the protests that were happening at
Israelis and you think the average
American looking at that would actually
sympathize with,
would simply would understand some of
the things he's been saying about what
the country has turned into.
Um,
you know,
Charlotte is just extraordinary.
You've got a black cop shooting and
seems to be an arm of black men and the
places being torn apart and our black
protestors showed another black protests
and stuff.
But it's
in a city with a democratic mayor.
Yeah.
And it,
but it is why she's fault somehow.
You know,
this black on black violence that's
happened as somehow a course for just
lutie and beatings and just a mass
mindless violence that's been
characterized as some sort of a protest
that's got some purpose and it doesn't,
it is just mindless looting and
violence.
And it should be called and what it is,
and again,
I think the public can see what it is,
but the media narrative is trying to
paint it as something other than that.
And I think that is a great,
uh,
the thing is something else we have in
common in Australia and America,
Europe is the media being out of touch
with its readers,
viewers,
listeners,
they're just increasingly,
there's a gap between members of the
media and the mainstream population.
And I think that's not healthy.
Yeah,
I think it's interesting that you used
the phrase out of touch because I think
one of the debates were constantly
having here and the reason that online
shows are working is that it's it,
is it out of touch or is it that they're
actually in it with the politicians?
Do you think it's,
it's like a sort of generational thing
and just the technology thing and you
know,
we're all walking around with phones,
so now we're all on the ground
journalists or,
or is it that they're actually in it
with the people in power so they have a
vested interest in keeping that game
going?
Or maybe both?
Well in the U S in might be a bit of
that.
In Australia I think it is that,
I think it's because they're part of the
establishment or the elite.
I think it's just the ideological
disposition of a great number of the
members of the media and it's,
it's,
it's quite many of them,
uh,
not,
you know,
then look at the mainstream,
well,
one,
they don't acknowledge the mainstream is
actually mainstream.
No,
they think quite often things because
they're surrounded by likeminded people
that their views or the prep one's views
and they're not,
or they just look at,
uh,
the mainstream with this sort of
condemnation as if they're too stupid to
believe what they believe.
Um,
and I think it's,
again,
really unhealthy at a time where the
mainstream media needs,
it needs its audience more than ever to
be poles apart from,
from what the great majority of the
population thinks,
I think is really unfortunate.
Yeah.
And I,
I,
in Australia anyway,
I think it's just a simple matter of the
politics of the individuals within the
media tends to be very much on the left
as it has in your been for the
generations.
And,
um,
and the,
the,
the rest of the population is a lot more
diverse than that.
It's a lot more nuanced than that.
You know?
Uh,
and,
uh,
and they've used aren't being properly
reflected.
Uh,
um,
of course there are conservative
commentators and writers and
journalists,
but very much in the minority and not
reflecting the number of voters who are,
um,
leaning that way.
Yeah.
How much of this stuff do you think is
actually just purely the fault of
education,
be it in Australia or be it here or
wherever?
I mean,
I was watching the,
the Charlotte,
uh,
the riot and there was this guy and they
found a protest or,
and he was screaming about trump.
And I'll preface this with saying,
this is not a defense of trump,
but trump is not empower.
Now he's not the president or the
governor of the state or the mayor of
that city.
And the guy was blaming trump.
And it's like,
I'm not saying you should be blaming
Hillary,
and I'm not even saying you should be
blaming Obama,
but you're,
you're misdirecting things at somebody
that has literally nothing to do.
No power in place has anything to do
with trump right now.
And to me,
that's an education problem,
not a,
a political problem.
Very much.
And a Yay.
It,
those opinions come from ignorance,
but they are supported again by quite
often by mainstream media.
Now I remember,
you know,
after even Orlando there was talk about
trump as if he had anything to do with
it.
The Alando massive gain is just absurd
to be blaming him.
You imagine how this news would be
reported if it was a bunch of trump
supporters were tearing apart a city
where,
you know,
bashing by standards or just the color
of this game who were looting and that
and just causing this widespread
widespread mayhem and destruction.
Yeah,
yeah.
It is.
It is completely idiotic.
But it's become almost a joke,
you know,
and whenever something horrible happens
around the world,
you know,
you'd be blame brexit.
You blame trump,
you blame the crusades.
You know,
you can't ever actually pin point the
blame at the people responsible.
Cause that would be,
you know,
probably racist and gross,
the gross and racist.
We know that.
Um,
I want to back up a little bit to some
of your history because you weren't
always a public person and a journalist
and someone that's,
you know,
staked out controversial positions.
You were actually,
you were a private citizen.
You were in banking at first,
right?
Laura,
yet
you to go from a,
a normal job to somebody that's,
that's out there putting their,
their face with their words.
I know I was in studio,
a same industry with the good prospects
and good income and you know,
that Matt.
And then we'll miss score if he just
wasn't for me.
I thought I want to go,
I want to go into an industry where
there's massive job losses and where I'm
going to be the tiniest of tiny
minorities.
Um,
it will,
it wasn't completely planned.
It was fairly accidental,
but he was a happy accident.
And,
uh,
you know,
I needed decade in,
in,
in finance and I think I enjoyed my
seven,
but by the end of it I just had enough.
And um,
uh,
I had much higher than that,
that point too.
So it sort of gave me an opportunity to
rethink things.
I went back to university,
I did my master's,
um,
which was a,
again,
that's kind of cemented some of my
thoughts about higher education and just
how many junk degrees there are.
Just completely pointless,
just settling basically.
Do you think higher education is a waste
altogether?
Right?
Oh No,
no,
not a waste all together.
I just think in Australia in particular
anyway,
there are so many of these junk degrees,
they don't qualify you to do anything
that saddled students with big debts,
raise their expectations and they come
out and they know more qualified for a
job.
And then when they went in and you know,
a lot of buddies just lefty
indoctrination posing as education.
It's just absurd.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I'm all for having even more degrees
for,
you know,
doctors and nurses and architects and
accountants,
things that actually,
you know,
teach you how to do a certain job,
but,
you know,
bloody,
uh,
master's in gender dance therapy or
something else or just,
um,
rides.
Anyway.
Um,
so yeah,
it will,
it was all,
uh,
again,
it wasn't planned.
I was,
it was a by chance and just,
uh,
I'm finding myself,
I guess,
so that's such a wonky term.
But Anyway,
um,
here I am and it's,
it's worked out well.
Yeah.
So here you are.
It's worked out well.
We,
we connected on twitter,
I don't know,
maybe six months ago or so.
And I thought,
wow,
here's someone else across the world,
uh,
who,
who gets it,
you know,
I,
I sense cares about the same things I
care about.
I see you every now and again.
You fight with some of the haters.
I'm not big on fighting with the haters
as a general rule.
And I see them spewing all sorts of
genuinely racist,
awful things at you.
They often,
they often think that you're another
nationality than you are,
or religion.
I think I'm Indian or Pakistani.
Yesterday I was copying it back.
Yesterday I had someone,
I told them,
I'm not Indiana cause you know,
all their sort of a piece was framed
around me being Indian or Hindu.
Like never,
never don't know anybody.
There had never been there.
I've got to know me and they just refuse
to accept it then I've know you are in
Dnx.
All thought it was hilarious.
Look,
it is a really fine balance.
I tell people,
you know,
if I'm giving them advice about
twitter's is like don't feed the trolls,
don't acknowledge them,
their attention seekers,
they're desperate for any sort of
attention.
So don't give them what they are looking
for.
But on the other hand,
every now and then I know my whole is
enjoyed.
It's good to call out some filthy
hypocrites and just highlight the EDC,
highlight BDC and hypocrisy and violence
of some of these social justice warriors
who think,
you know,
their,
their morals are pristine and who thinks
they're better than the rest of us,
but they're quite often fairly vile
human beings.
And I'm happy to mock them.
I'm happy to,
uh,
you know,
how like them to the followers and let
them have their fun with the mom.
But I knowledge the other way your way,
which is just don't acknowledge them
because you know,
I get literally some days,
thousands and thousands of mentions and
I can't even read all of them.
And I certainly don't,
you know,
respond to all of them.
Um,
and it does seem like sometimes,
you know,
the overwhelming bulk,
a decent comments,
intelligent comments that you're not
acknowledging and you're acknowledging
the loon lunatic.
Right?
And that seems to be a sort of cancer
counter intuitive.
But I think we've got to,
um,
highlight the mentality of these people,
particularly when they pretend to be
morally superior to the rest of us.
Right.
So that,
that's an interesting piece of this
cause we've got the social justice
warrior class that are moralizing all of
us and telling us how racist we are and
all this nonsense.
And then at the same time,
there absolutely is a piece of this
alright.
Thing that I've talked about bit a bit
on this show where I get it,
they're,
they're pepe the frog and Heran Bay and
they're trolling everybody and then they
get Hillary to talk about the frog and
they're just internet meme poster is
there shit posters and they want to
upset everybody and they,
I think they're perfectly harmless.
But I also do see the real white
nationalists stuff and I don't know how
much of that.
So my question to you really is,
do you think it's just I go back and
forth basically between thinking that
it's healthy when they get this stuff
out because then it's not just hidden
and secretive and even though they
anonymous whatever,
they're getting it out versus on another
hand.
In the last year I had seen more
blatant,
true hate,
uh,
than ever before on mine.
So I'm not sure which one I,
whether I think this is actually healthy
or,
or not.
Yeah,
I,
I'm,
I haven't set my mind to that too.
I'm not,
I'm not sure.
I mean,
you just seem like an absolute is sewer
at times.
Twitter,
you know,
more so than any other social media
forum.
It seems to be just a bio field slur
full of people who are miserable,
who just want to fight.
And,
uh,
yeah,
it,
uh,
those,
really not nasty Nazi,
uh,
types.
I haven't encountered too many.
I've had a few and I've just bought
them.
Um,
uh,
but there've been very few in numbers as
far as the ones attacking maze now that
I'm not sure of the size of that
population.
And I think it's any way Nia,
the size of the,
of the other side.
But yeah,
any sign of them isn't healthy.
And again,
I think they should be treated with
absolute disdain that should be called
out.
They should be mocked.
And that's what I tend to do.
I don't try to,
you know,
convince these people.
I ain't tried to reeducate them.
I just mock them because that's all they
deserve.
They don't deserve your time,
they don't deserve,
you know,
and I think twitter is a really dumb
forum for in depth arguments.
You know,
you just kind of have them,
it's just,
that's not the place for,
uh,
discussions.
Yeah.
You try to frame your point of view in
it as fewer characters as possible.
Um,
and if you actually trying to have a
proper discussion,
I just don't think that's the forum for
it.
Yeah.
Do you see a new center sort of lining
up all over the world?
Cause I think even a year ago or so,
people were barely talking about this.
I'm talking about the people that are
not the far right prue white
supremacists or racist or whatever you
want to call them.
And you know,
I don't like using all the buzzwords and
not,
and not the regressive left and all the
sjws and all that,
but that there is some sort of new
center lining up and it's because of the
Internet because people like us had been
able to,
uh,
to connect that my friend Ali Rizvi up
in Canada who's an atheist Muslim coined
the phrase,
the new center.
He said that's,
that's the new home politically.
Do you sense that this could actually
become a political
absolutely.
I think political parties are starting
to recognize what the electorate cares
about and they need,
you've got to think the Republicans have
to regroup over the next decade and
recognize that they abandoned their
base,
that they had so many people so
desperately unhappy with them.
Um,
and so eager to jump on the,
on the trump train and in Australia as
well,
you know,
in the last election,
uh,
something between one or 2 million
votes,
2 million voters.
And that's a significant figure here.
We're a small country of conservative
voters,
took their vote elsewhere from,
from the mainstream,
a conservative,
a liberal national coalition.
Um,
so I think there is this new center,
um,
and where it is,
is the question,
I think it's a far more,
uh,
to the right then the media class would
want it to be and acknowledge it to be,
um,
I don't mean their right wing.
I just think that,
you know,
in their economic point of view,
in their attitude to borders and
immigration and national security,
they're far more,
um,
conservative then then the media class,
uh,
would like them to be and acknowledging
them to be.
So I think the politicians have no
choice but to acknowledge it.
Yeah.
They can't ignore it.
Then their political survival depends on
it.
So,
um,
but whether you let me,
you actually see the emergence of the
new party is something else too to
ponder.
I'm not sure about that.
But um,
there's talk of that in Australia.
There's talk about,
um,
an actual new conservative party that
will bring in all these sort of minor
parties.
Losier's um,
but it hasn't happened.
It's something that's been talked about
or whether it actually been choice is
another question.
Yeah.
I think it's interesting that,
you know,
a second ago you started to say that
they're more right,
but you really meant conservative and
then you,
you fixed.
Yeah,
yeah.
I do to change,
but no,
no,
no.
But I,
I bring that up only because it's like
even people like you to make your point,
you still want to be so concerned about
the language.
And I feel that too,
because we're,
we're so just under this thing where if
you say one thing wrong and implied that
the conservatives are really far right
or that,
that everyone will be all over you.
And that what a,
what a crazy place for people like us to
be in.
Oh,
it's insane.
It is.
People are just so hyper sensitive to
the,
you know,
and so looking to be offended by
something or take something out of
context that you do sometimes,
you know,
even someone who doesn't want to,
doesn't give a stuff about political
correctness.
You find yourself qualifying things and
explaining things like over explaining
things.
It's,
yeah,
it's,
I guess we're not immune to it either.
We've,
we live in that world and we have to
acknowledge it.
I wish we were over.
I see people on twitter telling me
sometimes times we could see it get over
yourself,
like,
you know,
just stop.
But you know,
I'm,
I'm still trying to be a person that,
a good person that exists in 2016 so,
so my last,
my last question for you is taking
everything that we've discussed here,
um,
what do you think the best thing for,
for people that are,
that are hearing our messages,
whether they a little more right or
conservative or a little more left or
liberal or whatever it is for all of
these people that are hearing this and
seeing the same trends that you're
talking about all over the world,
what is the best thing that they can do
to help fix some of this stuff?
Be Brave.
Be Bold.
Say what she think.
I think that's the message to take out
of it.
Don't be afraid,
don't be bullied into silence.
Don't feel like,
uh,
your point of view isn't worthy of being
aired and discussed.
And don't worry about,
you know,
if you say something,
you're going to be unfriended on
facebook by someone you went to school
with 20 years ago.
You know,
I just think people need to be,
people need to be brave and have and be
interested.
You know,
be easy.
I wouldn't force anybody to,
to become political nuts,
but you know,
if you care about this stuff,
get interested,
read,
uh,
read different sources,
find out what's really happening and um,
don't be shy.
They're putting your 2 cents in.
Yeah.
Well I,
that's what I say on the,
on the show every week.
So I will co sign that one.
Alright.
Well,
Rita,
it was a pleasure.
I'm so glad we finally connected and we
were supposed to have you a couple of
days ago in our Internet blew out.
I think we,
somebody is watching us and they didn't
want us to connect.
Well,
I don't even believe that was just
coincidence.
There's obviously some sort of the left
wing conspiracy to silence.
Now.
I don't think there's any other
explanation possible.
Definitely some sort of left wing
conspiracy a.
Anyway,
you guys can follow Rita.
It's at Rita Panahi on twitter and she
can follow her writing,
uh,
over at the Australian Harold's son.
Uh,
Rita.
It was a pleasure.
So we'll,
we'll keep doing this in 140 characters.